cette résidente d'abbotsford devra
prendre un bateau si elle veut retourner
chez elle sa maison comme bien d'autres
ici est pratiquement submergé les pompes
ne réussissent pas encore à évacuer
l'eau
mais bien petite rue mansfield
tous n'ont pas un bateau mais ceux qui
en ont offert leur aide il n'avait que
dans ce qui était il y a quelques jours
des ruses et des chants
ils vont se courir des animaux qui sont
restés derrière
ces chiens n'ont pas mangé depuis trois
jours
comme l'expliquent le député d'abobo sud
des équipes tentent de colmater les
brèches dans les digues qui ont cédé
pour retenir l'eau qui continue de
s'écouler jusqu'ici cette zone
d'abbotsford qui était un lac il ya une
centaine d'années le lac sous masse est
aujourd'hui complètement inondé plus de
600 personnes ont dû être évacuées en
toute urgence cette semaine et les
autorités espèrent faire baisser le
niveau d'eau le plus rapidement possible
notamment pour permettre la couverture
de la route transcanadienne qui donne
accès à l'est de la province et au reste
du pays deux de
mes temps que l'eau ne se sera pas
retirée il faudra continuer de se serrer
les coudes et prendre les journées une à
la fois ici sébastien desrosiers
radio-canada a bottle